foreign
people knew that things were about to
change
[Music]
[Applause]
the American soldiers had arrived and
one of them had that unfortunate moment
where he climbed on top of the statue
and he put an American flag that had
shocked the few Iraqis who were on the
streets watching that flag was pulled
down quite quickly and then we saw these
men arriving putting a rope around the
statue and for hours trying to pull the
statue down to see that new Statue for
was basically the end of an era
let them foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
we heard gunshots people running for
those who were saying that the Americans
were here not to liberate Iraqis not for
the benefits of Iraqis the Americans
started losing the support of those they
needed the most
thank you
[Applause]
the Battle of Iraq the United States and
our allies have prevailed you had George
Bush on this big warship in the middle
of the sea uh he looked a bit like Tom
Cruise and Top Gun I remember watching
that on television being in Baghdad
it was a bit surreal because things were
beginning to unravel
[Music]
when this happened it's basically
on one side shocks the world
but on the other side it Vindicated all
those who had picked up arms already
against the uh occupation they were
there saying see this is what we were
talking about I remember there was hope
in Iraq
that
things would change a lot of people were
dreaming oh the Americans are going to
come in the Europeans are coming we're
going to live in Freedom
and the Suffering The Iraqis went
through because of such a badly planned
botched post-invasion
[Music]
was
painful to order
[Music]